real talk like this gives me a lot of
anxiety and I think about it it's really
hard to not think about it all the time
that like I'm 8 weeks away from like a
mystery Massacre correct that I'm scared
of and I have no idea what it's going to
be like you leave the
hospital in a wheelchair well that I
like now I'm good and now I'm home but
I'm just saying they put you in a
wheelchair that's when you're like oh
they won't let you walk to the car cuz
your uterus will fall out of
your I'm okay I hear you
like it's not a game dude women used to
die this is by the way all assuming you
survive child oh my God which is the
chances are very small that you will
even survive thank you for sharing that
what